la seguridad es fuerte en el castillo de
luxe y en su propietario mohamed bin
salman acaba de llegar a francia y fue
recibido por el ministro de economía uno
le maire se prevé que ese jueves por la
noche cené en el liceo invitado por el
presidente manuel marco para un
encuentro de trabajo la visita se
produce mientras la unión europea se
replantea sus vínculos con riad y toma
distancia junto con la mayor parte de la
comunidad internacional debido a la
presunta implicación del príncipe
saudita en el brutal asesinato del
periodista jamal kazuki pero mientras la
guerra en ucrania continúa europa se
enfrenta a una subida de los precios de
la energía y a un invierno con escasez
de petróleo y gas ruso una situación que
obliga al bloque europeo a buscar
fuentes alternativas
de mantener conversaciones con todos sus
países del golfo me parece absolutamente
necesario no significa que nos olvidemos
de cuestiones esenciales en materia de
derechos humanos hay que mantener el
diálogo
de montero antes de llegar a francia el
príncipe heredero firmó importantes
contratos en grecia el futuro monarca
está volviendo a la escena internacional
después de que el presidente
estadounidense joe biden se reuniera con
él a principios de este mes para los
defensores de los derechos humanos la
actual emergencia energética no debe
eclipsar la situación humanitaria en el
país del golfo
está tratando de crear una reputación
limpia entre los medios de comunicación
y en el ámbito diplomático pero no
olvidemos lo que realmente está
sucediendo en arabia saudita debe
permanecer en la mente de todos y todas
las personas con las que se reúna deben
recordarle que los derechos humanos
deben mejorar en arabia saudita y que
esta situación no puede ser aceptada
majón acaba de mantener diálogos con
líderes de abu dhabi y el cairo los
estrechos aliados del reino con una
acogida de alfombra roja que ha
consternado a los activistas